Hallo? Hallo? Chetke? Ich rede mit euch schon seit, ich rede mit euch schon seit ungefähr
5 Minuten. Jetzt, war ich wirklich die ganze Zeit gemutet? Ja? Na geil. Also nein, wir
machen heute kein C++, das ist einfach nur ein doofes Streamtitel und ich habe euch,
ich habe was, was, okay. Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was ich die letzten 5 Minuten erzählt
habe. Irgendwelche random Sachen, die ich sonst so erzähle. Ich habe euch gefragt,
was bei euch so gegangen ist heute, dass es bei mir übelst anstrengend war, dass ich
meine SSD-Firmware geupdatet habe. Ja, das habe ich euch auch gezeigt. Guck hier, ich
habe meine SSD-Firmware geupdatet. Hier, na, sieht man. Weil ich war gestern richtig
geschockt, als ich gesehen habe, dass meine SSD einfach auf 94% Realleveling runter ist.
Habe ich gesagt, ich mache mal kurz ein Update von meiner VM. Wie das jetzt ging, ja, wie
das jetzt ging, ist ganz einfach. Ich habe einfach die Software nochmal neu installiert
und dann ging es. Ich habe nicht mal rebooted, ich habe die Software einfach nochmal neu
installiert und dann ging es. Man weiß nicht, warum. So, kurz hier updaten nochmal, habe
ich rebooted. Ja, was habe ich euch sonst noch erzählt? Ja, dass es bei mir anstrengend
gewesen ist, wie es bei euch heute gewesen ist, habe ich gefragt. Dann, ja, ich wollte
von euch wissen, Chat-Gewalt, ich weiß doch, ihr seid extremely 5Head und highIQ, der Chat
hier auf Twitch. Hat jemand von euch schon mal was mit RabbitMQ gemacht? Kennt ihr euch
da aus? So wie der Hase, schreibt man das. Nur MQ hintendran. Das Profi in RabbitMQ.
Nice. Embedded RabbitMQ. Weil, wenn jetzt jemand gesagt hätte, ja, kenne ich mich voll
aus, hätte ich gefragt, hat das schon mal einer von euch auf Kubernetes laufen gehabt
und Erfahrung mit dem Kubernetes RabbitMQ Operator. Ja, das Ding, das heißt wirklich
so. Ich habe das auch schon benutzt. Ich habe sogar mal einen Cluster gebaut aus drei
Nodes, aber das waren 4Ms und bei uns steht jetzt an, dass man das wahrscheinlich auf
Kubernetes laufen lassen muss, was nicht schwierig ist. Also in sich ist das ziemlich easy, aber
ich weiß ja nicht, ob es da nicht irgendwelche Fallstricke gibt, wie bei so ziemlich allem,
was man auf Kubernetes laufen lässt. Und Chat, ich habe noch eine Frage an euch. Eventuell
gibt das, also wenn ihr die jetzt ordentlich beantwortet, PostChamp, dann gibt es vielleicht
sogar Content für euch im Stream. Und zwar, wir haben einen Konsultant bei uns auf der
Arbeit. Der, ich glaube, der ist nicht so alt, Leute. Ich würde mal sagen, der ist 25. Der
ist auch kein Konsultant. Den haben sie für Security-Sachen im Kubernetes-Umfeld eingekauft.
Der ist, glaube ich, irgendwie 25 oder so. Und der hat eine eigene Security-Firma gegründet
vor ein paar Jahren, also vor zwei, drei Jahren oder so, die sich explizit auf Cloud-Native-Kubernetes-Security
spezialisiert hat. Was meint ihr, wäre das eine sinnvolle Idee, den mal in den Stream
einzuladen, dass der uns ein bisschen was über Kubernetes-Security erzählt? Das macht
der bestimmt. Der hat bestimmt Bock drauf. Ich meine, natürlich müssen wir ihm dann
zugestehen, dass der ein bisschen Sellout macht im Stream. Der ist super agil. Natürlich
darf er ein bisschen Sellout machen für seine Firma und ein paar Aufträge einsacken
oder so. Also das ist tatsächlich einer der Konsultants, wo ich sagen würde, ja, mit
dem kommt man gut klar und der weiß auch, was er macht. Nicht so wie die meisten anderen
Laber-Konsultants. Dann muss ich mir das mal merken. Ja, die haben sich tatsächlich
auf Kubernetes-Security und, sagen wir mal so, links und rechts Cloud-Geschichten spezialisiert.
Die waren auch letztens auf irgendeiner Kubernetes-Konferenz und haben dort Talks gehalten, die zwei Gründer
und so. Also die sind schon wirklich pfeiffert, was das Thema angeht. Die können bestimmt
uns erzählen, was so die dümmsten Sachen sind, was man machen kann. Ich meine, dazu
muss ich mir im Vorfeld mal irgendeine Cluster professionieren, dass wir ein bisschen was
zeigen können. Aber das ist kein Problem. Dann frage ich den mal, weil ich glaube, der
hat da schon prinzipiell Bock drauf, so wie ich den einschätze jetzt einfach mal. Und
natürlich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen Sellout für die Firma ist nicht verkehrt, was auch
wirklich nicht schlecht ist, weil ich weiß, wir haben hier im Chat auch durchaus Leute,
die Aufträge, Dienstleister raussuchen, Aufträge vergeben und bestimmt auch Leute, die Probleme
haben im Cloud-Umfeld. Also ein bisschen Sellout ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Kann man ja
nebenbei machen. Das glaube ich auch tatsächlich, ja. Die sagen auch, dass sie nicht alles wissen,
sondern sich hauptsächlich auf Kubernetes und Cloud-Security sachen. Einen privaten Cluster
wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht verlieren, der steht ja nicht im Internet. Leisten die im
ganzen Bundesgebiet? Ja, soweit ich weiß schon. Aber bevor ich hier irgendwelche Aufträge vermittel,
will ich erstmal wissen, wie man das mit Provision macht. Ne, bevor das ist, müssen wir auf jeden
Fall erstmal Stream machen. Dann könnt ihr euch das ja mal anhören, wenn ihr denkt,
Alter, die sind pfeifett, dann darf er ja ruhig ein bisschen Sellout machen hier so
nach dem Motto Aufträge hier und so. Gibt's Subs als Provision? Das soll mir auch recht
sein. Wie ihr mir die Kohle zukommen lasst, Digga. Ne, da bist du nicht der Einzige. Da bist
du nicht der Einzige. Ich finde halt, hat NetCap ein Managed Kubernetes oder hast du da VMs und
lässt deine Sache selbst drauflaufen? Ich habe heute erfahren, dass Teile meiner Arbeiten an
einer neuen, anderen Stelle ausgeschrieben werden. Andere Abteilung. Was soll man davon halten? Ja,
kommt das jetzt dazu noch? Also kriegst du es einfach alleine nicht gebacken? Brauchen die noch
mehr Leute? Da fehlt ein bisschen der Kontext drumherum. Vielleicht machst du ja einfach zu
viel unterschiedliches Zeug. Ich mein, frag doch einfach mal, was mit euch los? Wie kommt's? Ich
mein, so einfach aus heiterem Himmel kommt doch sowas normalerweise nicht. Und wenn doch, dann
würde ich erstmal cack waiten. Aber warum kann man doch mal blöd fragen? So wie jetzt? Was soll
ich denn davon halten? Ganz ehrlich, ich würde davon abraten, ein Kubernetes selbst einzurichten.
Selbst auf Cloud VMs. Da muss man einiges wissen dazu und da kann man auch sich relativ schnell
irgendwelche Fallstricke bauen. Zumal es, wenn es eine VM mit dem Service, der direkt da drauf
läuft, auch tut. So, habe ich jetzt eigentlich die VM schon rebooted? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Guck mal, letztes Command oder so ist wahrscheinlich noch reboot. Nice. Ja,
ansonsten keiner von euch Erfahrung mit RapidMQ im Kubernetes-Umfeld? Da müsste ich mich nämlich
mal konsultieren lassen von euch. Ne, umgedreht. Ich müsste euch, den Chat mal konsultieren.
Jemand, der es am besten macht. Aber morgen ist Freitag. Das ist schon mal extremely pog. Chat,
freut sich irgendjemand auf Baldur's Gate 3? Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Da ist nämlich Release
Date in ungefähr vier Wochen. Ja, 1.3.3. August. Du hast es schon seit einem Jahr. Das ist die
Early Access Version mit dem ersten Akt und da wahrscheinlich auch nicht alles. Ich weiß,
es gibt Leute, die haben schon über 1000 Stunden in der Early Access Version. Wisst ihr, ich freue
mich auch extrem auf das Game. Aber eine Sache, eine Sache finde ich ein bisschen doof. Ja,
also es gibt zwei Sachen. Es gibt zwei Sachen. Die, also eine Sache könnte doof sein. Das weiß
ich nicht. Da muss ich zu spielen. Und eine Sache finde ich jetzt schon doof. Und zwar das Erste
ist, dass es irgendwie in den Videos immer wie in Divinity Originals in 3 wirkt. Von der ganzen
Optik und Aufmachung wirkt es eher wie so ein Divinity Game. Außer die Spell Icons und so. Ja,
die haben es sich schon inspirieren lassen. Vielleicht wirkt das aber auch nur in Videos
so. Mal gucken. Es wirkt für mich nicht wie in Baldur's Gate, aber muss man mal schauen. Und
das Zweite ist, was mir persönlich nicht gefällt, dass es nur vier Spielercharaktere gibt. Also,
wie nennen wir das? Vierer Party Size. Das mag ich nicht, weil die alten Baldur's Gate Teile
hatten immer sechs. Sechser Partys. Und Sechser Partys sind eigentlich auch für mich der beste
Kompromiss, aus wie man noch ganz gut Encounter designen kann und dass man alles hat und auch
ein bisschen Variation drin hat. Weil mit vierer Party hast du ehrlich gesagt, gerade nachdem das
auf 5th Edition basiert, irgendwie fehlt mir da so ein bisschen die Variation. Du brauchst ja
eh so ein paar Sachen immer. Das heißt für irgendwie so Special Klassen hast du da eigentlich
keinen Platz für. Du brauchst immer einen Clary. Du brauchst immer einen Wizard. Sowas in der
Richtung. Ich glaube die Entwicklung von Baldur's Gate ging los mit Include Divinity Punkt H. Da gehe
ich auch von aus. Wilder Igel, Dankeschön für den Sub. Excellent Subscription. Also ich weiß nicht,
ob es da nicht zu wenig Variationen gibt in dem, was man spielen kann, wenn man es auf höherem
Schwierigkeitsgrad spielt. Weil es gibt zwar relativ, also es gibt die ganzen Base Classes
und auch sehr viele Subclasses und alles. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt die passende
Dungeons & Dragons Terminologie ist. Aber du brauchst ja immer so vier Basic Sachen. Du brauchst
mindestens einen Caster und am besten mindestens einen Wizard. Du brauchst mindestens einen Clary. Du brauchst
mindestens einen, sagen wir mal, Fighter, Parlor, sonst was in der Richtung. Ja und gerade falls du
in dem Spiel Rationen managen musst, ich weiß nicht wie es ist, ob es Ration Packs und sowas
gibt, brauchst du am besten auch noch einen Ranger. Da brauchst du nämlich keine Rationen
mehr mitnehmen. Also insofern, ja und dann hast du eigentlich deine Party schon voll und dann wäre
es eigentlich erst lustig geworden. Dann könntest du auf dem fünften Platz eine Bahne mitnehmen,
auf dem sechsten Spot einen Warlock oder irgendwie sowas. Aber mit vier Klassen ist
es einfach so ein bisschen beschränkt. Ich weiß nicht. Mal gucken, ob das wirklich so schlimm ist,
aber das gefällt mir nicht. Ich hätte lieber eine Sechser-Party gehabt. Ja, man konnte die
alten Teile auch Solo spielen, aber wenn man das als Party-Game spielt, dann finde ich eine
Sechser-Party das Beste. Man konnte die alten Teile Solo spielen zu zwei, zu dritt, zu vier,
zu fünf, zu sechs, war egal. Es gibt Leute, die sagen auch die alten Baldur's Gate Teile waren
am besten balanced für eine Vierer-Party, obwohl du eine Sechser-Party spielen konntest. Wobei die
alten Baldur's Gate Teile ein Problem hatten mit vielen der eingebauten NPCs, dass die Stats der
eingebauten NPCs halt abgrundtief mies waren. Pala mit 13 Stärke oder sowas. Ja gut,
deswegen hätte ich gesagt Ranger. Druide kannst du auch spielen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Circle of
Moon und sowas gibt mit Shapeshift. Dann könnte der theoretisch sogar als, naja, als Off-Tank
vielleicht fungieren. Aber ich finde Druide kannst du auch erst so richtig schön mitnehmen, wenn du
so die Basics für eine Party abgedeckt hast, so als fünften Charakter oder so. So einen Wizard
brauchst du oder sagen wir mal Wizard-Sorg brauchst du, wobei ich ja persönlich Wizard besser finde.
Gut, ich bin mal gespannt. Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall mega auf das Game und ich bin gespannt,
ob sie ein paar Referenzen auf die alten Games drin haben. Also was ich jetzt schon erkannt
habe ist, dass die Spell-Icons und die ein oder andere... Minsk ist glaube ich auch wieder mit
dabei. Der Typ mit seinem Hamster. Und ansonsten weiß ich nicht, was da sonst noch so alles an
Referenzen zu den alten Teilen drin sind. Also ich habe Baldur's Gate 1 und 2 jetzt nicht 50 Mal
oder so durchgespielt, aber auch ein paar Male. Was ich nicht mochte ist, also ich mochte Baldur's
Gate 1, fand ich mega nice. Baldur's Gate 2 fand ich mega nice. Die Baldur's Gate 1,
das Baldur's Gate 1 Addon fand ich auch ganz nice. Was ich persönlich nicht mochte ist die
Baldur's Gate 2, das Baldur's Gate 2 Addon. Das wirkte auf mich lieblos und nicht auf dem
Qualitätsstandard wie die restliche Serie. Ich meine, es war schon okay, gerade weil es recht
viel Hack and Slag im Endeffekt war, aber Throne of Baal mochte ich nicht so wirklich. Bin gespannt,
ob das was wirkt, ob das ansatzweise an die alten Teile anknüpfen kann. Wenn nicht und es einfach
nur ein gutes Rollenspiel wird, ist auch okay, aber bei dem Name wäre es schon wirklich nice.
Divinity war tatsächlich sehr pock. Den ersten Teil habe ich gespielt auf dem allerhöchsten
Schwierigkeitsgrad, das war gar nicht so einfach. Den zweiten Teil habe ich tatsächlich nie komplett
fertig gespielt. Divinity finde ich, also der zweite Teil hat für mich, sagen wir mal so bei
zwei Drittel, also nach der Hälfte bis zu zwei Drittel hat er ziemlich nachgelassen. Die erste
Hälfte war auf jeden Fall der beste Teil an Divinity, Original Sin 2. Da hat es ein bisschen
nachgelassen. Irgendwie hatte ich keinen Bock mehr. Meistens beende ich so Games ja auch, wenn ich die
erst mal angefangen habe, aber bei Original Sin 2 hatte ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock,
fertig zu spielen. Ah, ich sehe schon wieder Pfeiffer Talk im Chat. Magst du dich ans Trinken
erinnern? Sehr gute Idee. Exzellent. So muss das sein. Siehst du, immer schön die Channel Points
ausgeben. Ne, Leute, es ist heute alles von Amazon gekommen. Alles was ich bestellt habe,
liegt hier von Amazon hinter mir, außer Milfra. Nur Milfra kommt erst am Samstag. Dabei ist Milfra,
das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen falsch an für alle, die im Stream nicht dabei waren. Nur Milfra
ist das, was mich am meisten interessiert, weil neun Euro für ein Vierer-Pack ist schon echt
günstig. Übrigens soll ich euch mal ein Fun-Fact, ne, was anderes. Vielleicht weiß es jemand von
euch. Wisst ihr, wer hinter der Domain, wer hinter dieser Domain hier steht? Unterderbrücke.de.
Nicht, nicht spicken, nicht spicken. Sagt mir, ob ihr es wisst oder nicht. Wisst ihr,
wisst ihr, wo ihr rauskommt, wenn ihr auf unterderbrücke.de hingeht? Ich hätte das auch
nie gedacht. Ihr wisst es nicht. Man kommt bei Gmx raus. Das ist eine alternative Domain von
Gmx. Du kannst auch E-Mail-Adressen dahin schicken. Du kannst maxmustermannatunterderbrücke.de
schicken und da kommt es bei deinem Gmx-Postfach raus. Ich habe absolut keinen flassen Schimmer,
warum diese Domain zu Gmx gehört. Unter der Brücke. Kein C++, danke für den Prime-Sub,
gerade noch mal abgewendet hier. Sehr schön, PyFer-Time. Hallo zusammen, ich wollte mal das
Thema E-Mail-Provider umziehen angehen und meine alte Jugendadresse von Gmx obsolet machen. Wieso
Gmx taugt doch eigentlich ganz gut. Okay, keine Ahnung, kann ich dir nichts zu sagen, aber ich
finde Gmx taugt doch ganz gut. Was hast du gegen Gmx? Also, wenn du da schon eine E-Mail hast. Noch
nicht, erst wenn du den nächsten Monat nicht erneuerst. Also, wenn es diese Adresse geben
sollte, dann kommt die da auch an, ja. Achso, ja gut, dann verstehe ich es. Silvercross,
dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, warum nicht? Ich glaube, mein Zahnarzt hat auch bei Gmx eine
E-Mail-Adresse. Ich glaube, es stand bei ihm auf der Homepage. Wieso nicht? Ich finde Gmx-E-Mail-Adressen
gar nicht so wild. Ich meine, natürlich, wenn man eine Domain hat, dann ist es natürlich sinnvoller,
man macht sich eine Weiterleitung auf seine Gmx-E-Mail-Adresse, dann liegt man auch keine
Adressen, aber warum nicht? SirGentleFrog, POG-Subscription. Das ist extrem. Also, ich mache es
mittlerweile so. Ich habe ja, also der Vorteil, wenn man ganz viele unsinnige Domains hat, wie
ich, dann kannst du easy Weiterleitungen machen, kannst du noch mehr sinnlose Weiterleitungen
machen. Zum Beispiel unter anderem, wobei, ihr müsst jetzt nicht spammen, das kommt eh nicht auf
meine Haupt-E-Mail-Adresse raus, das kommt auf irgendeine Gammel-E-Mail-Adresse bei Gmx,
witzigerweise, raus. Wie zum Beispiel, warum wird die E-Mail-Adresse nicht mehr eingeblendet jetzt?
Dann kann ich doch nicht leaken. Nekorok, danke schön für den Sub. Ne, lol, ich habe mich verguckt,
aber schön, dass du da bist. Ich habe es nur aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, habe ich gedacht,
hier, Start, Prime-Subscription, aber hier, du hast ja auch schon, 29 Monate, POG-Cringe.
Dollarzeichen sind nicht erlaubt in E-Mail-Adressen. Ich habe das jetzt einfach mal gesagt, ich habe
keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt. Ich vermute aber, dass es nicht erlaubt ist. Was haben wir da? Ach
ja, ist das die Milfra-Steckdose? Ja, das ist aber von 2018, Tuya Convert. Tuya Convert geht bei
meiner nicht, also ich werde die Steckdose wahrscheinlich aufschrauben müssen, um reinzuschauen,
ob da überhaupt noch ein ESP drin ist. Ja. Oh, Chat-G, ich bin heute übelst kaputt. Ich wollte
mit euch demnächst mal wieder einen Konferenz-Talk gucken, und zwar den hier. Nicht heute,
das packen wir zeitlich nicht. Ich wollte mit euch mal wieder einen Konferenz-Talk gucken,
nämlich den hier. Fand ich mega cool gemacht, falls den schon jemand geguckt hat. Da geht es
um Software-Entwicklungs-Fails, zum Beispiel um den Madfile-Unfucker und noch andere Dinger.
Fand ich sehr nice. Ja, da kann ich jetzt nicht spoilern, das müssen wir uns zusammen angucken.
Was ist das für ein schönes Aquarium? Das ist Ascii-Aquarium. Das hat übrigens auch ein paar
Features. Man kann die Fische auch schneller, noch schneller und super schnell schwimmen lassen.
Und mittelschnell, ja, mittelschnell und superschnell oder auch gar nicht. Und was
noch viel besser ist, du kannst es pipen nach lolcat. Dann hast du das Kappa-Pride-Aquarium.
Aber das ist ganz schön anstrengend, auf Dauer drauf zu gucken. Kennst du den USB-Geschichte
Talk von CC? Nee, nee. Ehrlich gesagt, die USB-Standards sind aber auch so abfuckt,
wahrscheinlich will ich die Geschichte gar nicht wissen. Guck mal, der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Data Science studieren, so ist es wirklich. Data Science klingt,
als macht man die ganze Zeit einfach nur irgendwelches Mathe-Zeug.
Data Science. Kann man das Ascii-Aquarium auch auf normalen OS laufen lassen? Ist doch ein normales
OS. Ist sogar das beste normale OS, was es gibt. Arch Linux, by the way. Drei Sekunden für den
Scam-Train, Leute. Nee, what? Gebate? Habt ihr das gesehen? Da stand eben einfach 53 Sekunden oben
und jetzt ist er weg. Die haben uns hart gebatet. Du meinst Chrome OS? Unter Chrome OS kannst du
das auch laufen lassen. Du kannst Ascii-Aquarium überall laufen lassen, wo es einen Perl-Interpreter
gibt, weil Ascii-Aquarium ist, man glaubt es nicht, ist ein Perl-Programm. Mr. Brawls,
dankeschön für den Sub. Ich sollte öfter so Stream-Titel machen. Nice, nice, nice, nice,
nice. Ja, also das ist ein Perl-Programm. Das ist ernsthaft, jetzt, Leute, Schweigeminute für
Perl. Aber das ist ernsthaft. Das einzige Perl-Programm, was ich benutze. Benutzt du
eigentlich Arch auf der Arbeit? Nee, ich habe einen Notebook mit Windows, aber ich habe zum
Glück eine, Ubuntu ist es, glaube ich, eine Ubuntu-VM, wo ich Root-Rechte drauf habe. Rust
Rewrite, okay, Rust Ascii-Aquarium. Gucken, ob es das gibt. Alter, vor zwölf Jahren. Perl,
100% in Perl. Keine Chance, gibt es noch kein Rust Rewrite von. Auf den Krempel hat niemand
Bock, den Rust zu machen. Das müssten wir echt bauen. Was ist Perl eigentlich für eine Sprache?
Eine alte und eine hässliche Sprache. Eine Sprache, die sehr viel Ragex benutzt für alles
Mögliche. Es gibt nicht umsonst heute noch den Ausdruck Perl-kompatible Ragex. Ich glaube,
ich, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das ist das, was von Perl irgendwie noch am meisten hängen geblieben
ist. Und das Witzige ist, wisst ihr, dass Perl sich selbst gekillt hat? Die haben einfach zu
lang mit der neuen Version gebraucht, die dann nie kam und dann haben sie eine eigene Runtime
gebaut, die dann auch ewig Verspätung hatte. Die haben sich einfach selbst gekillt. Und natürlich,
dass es dann irgendwann mal etwas angenehmere Alternativen zu Perl gegeben hat. Was der Sinn
dahinter war, hinter Perl ursprünglich, also ich kenne die Geschichte hinter Perl nicht,
aber ich vermute mal, okay, gibt es das in Rust, ja? Ich vermute mal, dass du was Einfaches hast,
als Bash-Alternative für so quick and dirty Automatisierung und Abläufe automatisieren,
ja. Vermute ich jetzt mal. Ascii Aquarium Screensaver vor Windows vor vier Jahren. Also
die Webseite, die ist wirklich sehr Web 5.0. ESX hat viel Perl, uah. Ich dachte immer,
ESX ist eigentlich hauptsächlich ein Redhead. Aber gut, was die, was die ESX-Leute für ihre
Management-Sachen da drauf, da drauf aufsetzen und gebaut haben, ja, vielleicht ist es schon so
alt, dass da wirklich noch viel Perl ist. Möglich, möglich, kann ja sein, kann ja sein. Ich bin so
im Arsch heute, was ist denn los? Bin vorhin, war ich zwei Stunden noch unterwegs, Sport gemacht,
aber daran liegt es nicht. Das mache ich jeden Tag, aber ich bin heute irgendwie ausgesprochen
kaputt. Ich frage mich immer oder immer öfters, wie habe ich das früher durchgehalten? Fünf Tage
die Woche, acht Stunden am Tag zu arbeiten. Chat, erklärt mir das mal, wie ist das möglich
überhaupt? Das geht doch gar nicht. Also das geht nicht, ohne dass du komplett im Arsch bist,
oder? Lieber Proxmox oder ESX vor MWare? Ich denke, das hängt davon ab, was du machen willst.
Wenn das irgendwelche Enterprise-Geschichten sind, wo du im Zweifelsfall auch noch supportete
Plattformen brauchst für Software, die da drauf läuft oder du besonderes Know-How hast in ESX
und Support kaufen möchtest, dann auf jeden Fall vor MWare. Oder du irgendwelche Features brauchst,
die nur vor MWare kann oder irgendwelche Software, die besonders tolle vor MWare-Integrationen hat,
dann vor MWare. Ansonsten kannst du auch Proxmox nehmen. Das vor MWare-Ökosystem ist doch insgesamt
noch etwas reifer vielleicht als Proxmox. Aber ich muss sagen, das letzte Mal, als wir uns Proxmox
angeguckt haben, ich fand das gar nicht schlecht gemacht. Das Container-Hosting könnte ein bisschen
schöner sein, aber ich fand das nicht übel gemacht. Auch das Clustern zwischen unterschiedlichen Nodes
ging, wenn man weiß, was man macht, nachdem man es mal verkackt hat, 1-2 mal, auch ganz gut. Die
Ceph-Integration ist mega nice. Das ist total einfach, ein Ceph aufzusetzen damit. Also ich
fand es echt nicht verkehrt. Du kannst direkt Container hosten bei Proxmox. Ja, aber ich finde
es nicht schön umgesetzt. Kannst du Firmen für ein Praktikum als Software-Entwickler empfehlen?
Ne. Also ich würde erstmal sagen, such dir was in der Nähe, die auch Praktikanten nehmen. So viele
wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht geben, wenn du nicht gerade in Frankfurt wohnst. Ich habe nächste
Woche ein Java-Backend-Vorstellungsgespräch. Exzellent. Das ist Pog. Da kannst du gleich denen
mal sagen, sie sollen eine ordentliche Sprache benutzen und wieder abhauen. Ne, ganz ehrlich,
es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm. Ich flame immer ganz gern gegen Java, aber im Endeffekt ist ganz
viele Business-Enterprise-Software in Java und es ist auch nach wie vor sehr angesagt. Ich
persönlich würde neues Springboot, das ist auch tatsächlich das einzige aktuelle was ich in Java
kenne oder öfters sehe und höre. Ich persönlich würde ja wenn überhaupt was in Kotlin machen,
wenn ich was auf JVM-Basis entwickeln möchte. Wir haben das glaube ich auch noch in unserem
To-Do drinne stehen. Habt ihr euch eigentlich auch schon mal Gedanken gemacht in die Schweiz
auszuwandern? Ne. Ich meine, ich habe hier ein Haus und sonst auch alles. Warum sollte ich
auswandern? Hausge, ja. Hausge, das ist so ein dummes Wort. Es gibt Leute, die sind in die
Schweiz ausgewandert, beziehungsweise die leben glaube ich schon immer in der Schweiz, hier im
Chat. Wir haben sogar ein paar Bayern hier im Chat, glaube ich. Ich war heute in Bayern und ich
dachte eigentlich, dass die immer noch sagen als Standardbegrüßung, grüß Gott. Ist das nicht mal
so? Sagen wahrscheinlich nur noch die alten Bayern, die sagen grüß Gott. Servus sagen die,
nicht grüß Gott. Aber früher haben die in Bayern immer grüß Gott gesagt. Die waren auch so super
christlich und so, grüß Gott. Heute sagen die Servus, ja. Ich bin sogar öfters in Bayern,
weil ich nicht weit von der hessisch-bayerischen Grenze weg wohne und in Bayern ist einfach viel
schöner zum rumlaufen und wandern als in Hessen. Also zumindest von der Entfernung zu meinem
Standort. Generell der Süden ist sehr christlich. Richtiger banger boomer Witz. Also ich mache zwei
Sachen in Bayern öfters, tatsächlich. Wandern, gehen und essen. Das war es eigentlich. Dann gehe
ich wieder. Also die wichtigsten Sachen schon mal erledigt. Bewegung und Essen. Hacker-Man-Shit
kann ich dann daheim ausmachen. Dann muss ich nicht in Bayern zu sein. Chat, gibt es noch
irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen zu klären heute? Will noch jemand Feedback zu jener Stellenanzeige,
wo er sich bewerben will? Das war doch letztens der Dauerbrenner. Das hatten wir jetzt schon ein
paar Tage nicht mehr. Ach guck mal, Visual Studio Code Update. Gut, dass wir das von 80 auf 8,
ach nee, 0,1 auf 1. Okay, let's go. Bierbrezel Weißwurst. Heißt es nicht Brezen in Bayern?
Brezen? Oder ist Brezen einfach die Mehrzahl? Ich glaube, die Bayern sagen zu einer Brezel
und zu mehreren Brezeln Brezen. In München? Ja, München ist teuer. Habe bei HP eine Stelle als
Storage Specialist gesehen für 300, 310k. Naja, da gibt es aber wahrscheinlich auch nur eine
Handvoll an Leuten, die sich dafür eignen werden. Oh, jetzt geht es aber hier instant los. Hatte
man das nicht letztens erst schon? Ein System Engineer und ein Cloud-Plattform-Kuber,
Kubernetes-Engineer. Ein Cades-Engineer, wie ich das jetzt auch schon ausgesprochen gehört habe.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, irgendwie finde ich die Abkürzung Cades cringe. Extrem cringe. Aber es
gibt auch Leute, die sagen nicht Cube CTL, sondern Cube Cuttle. Ja, deswegen finde ich die Abkürzung
ja auch so blöd. Ich meine, okay, K8S, natürlich kann man es Cades aussprechen, aber ich finde es
einfach nur richtig, richtig cringe. Aber ich habe ja schon alle Abkürzungen irgendwie gehört,
oder alle Aussprachen gehört. Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, Kubernetes, alles dabei.
Moment, ProSieben. Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Was sucht denn ProSieben? ProSieben
sucht erstmal ein Dark Theme, habe ich gehört. Wie? Ja, schon besser. Alter, die Seite ist kaputt
mit Dark Theme. Was macht ProSieben denn da? Okay, so geht es halbwegs. Lohnt es sich,
mein Unraid XFS Raid 6 auf ZFS zu ändern? Nö, wenn es läuft wahrscheinlich nicht,
seit du brauchst die ZFS-Feature, also Snapshots und solche Geschichten. Turn Code into Experience.
Okay, was? Alter, meine Güte. Und das ist jetzt die Werbung gewesen dafür? Oben rechts ist Dark
Mode tatsächlich. Ja, krasser Dark Mode, oder? Mega Dark Mode, würde ich sagen. Absoluter,
absoluter Poggers Dark Mode. Der Dark Mode ist besser. Okay, also jetzt, was wollen die mit,
was wollen die mit diesem? Sag mal, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Battlefield 2042 Trailer.
We are looking for techies who turn code into experience. Ob es irgendeinen Entwickler gibt,
der sich hierdurch angesprochen fühlt? Das ist eher so, irgendein Marketing-hyperaktiver
Videoschneider ist der Meinung, dafür interessieren sich dann die Leute. Na gut,
aber vielleicht gibt es ja doch welche. Also, zeigt mal her. Ein Netzwerkadministrator. Ach,
die suchen ja gar keinen Entwickler. Aber trotzdem, ich glaube, Netzwerkadmin spricht
das nicht so an. Und warum ein Typ mit Bademütze? Echt, habe ich jetzt gar nicht
geguckt. Hat der eine Bademütze an? Stimmt, der hat eine... Nee, der hat eine normale Mütze an,
das sieht nur so aus wie eine Bademütze. Guck mal, der hat doch hier hinten so ein
Schild über dem Kopf. Aber das sieht trotzdem aus wie eine Bademütze ein bisschen. Ja,
hast schon recht. Okay, lass mal kurz lesen. Was haben sie am Start bei ProSieben? Also,
das Team Network Service Solutions. Wetten, dass sie das intern abkürzen? NSS oder sowas? Das Team
Network Services Solutions. Sollte das nicht eigentlich Network Service Solutions? Die
Abkürzung ist schwierig. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber ich kenne viele Unternehmen, die neigen halt
dazu, so die Teams immer mit den ersten Buchstaben abzukürzen. Ich war auch mal in einem Team,
das hat sich einfach Server Admin genannt. Abkürzung war SA. Ist halt vielleicht auch
ein bisschen unglücklich, ja. Das Team Network Service Solutions konzipiert,
baut und betreibt die gesamte LAN, WAN, WLAN, Telco und Rechenzentrums Landschaft. Dazu zählen auch
alle LAN-based Security Plattformen. Okay. Ich weiß zwar nicht genau, was mir das jetzt sagen soll,
aber okay. Ich bin ja auch kein Netzwerk-Administrator. Was? Du arbeitest in IT H&I.
Handel? Handel und Investment? Und was heißt's? Helpdesk und Infrastruktur. Okay. Ich hab gecheatet.
Ich hab gecheatet. Ich dachte, du bist derjenige, der letztens geschrieben hat, dass er auch bei
einer Bank arbeitet. Da hab ich das durcheinander gebracht. Deswegen hab ich jetzt an Bank-Stonksachen
gedacht. Okay. Also was LAN-based Security... Ich weiß wirklich nicht, was LAN-based Security
Plattformen sind. LANSicherheit. Irgendwelche Cisco-Zeuche. Der LAN Edge Campus. Die haben
auch irgendeinen Random Generator für Produktbezeichnungen, oder? Ich kann das den Namen
nicht aussprechen, aber ist das etwa der ChainLaw? Dankeschön, asiatische Zeichen für den PrimeSub.
Das Team stellt damit Netzwerklösungen rund um den Office- sowie Broadcast-Betrieb
unseres Unternehmens zur Verfügung. Okay. In dieser Rolle lebst du unser hybrides Modell
flexibel. Was soll denn dieser Satz bedeuten? In dieser Rolle lebst du unser hybrides Modell
flexibel. Hä? Ich verstehe nur Bahnhof bei dem Satz. Was wollen die mir sagen damit?
Ich lebe das ihr hybrides Modell flexibel. Die haben ein hybrides Modell, was sich flexibel
nennt. Ja, das ist ja genauso unverständlich, was damit gemeint ist. Du wirst ein bis zwei
feste oder... Ach so! Ach, das ist damit gemeint! Alter, ich hätte vielleicht mal weiterlesen
sollen. Du wirst ein bis zwei feste oder flexible Tage vor Ort arbeiten. An den anderen Tagen kannst
du remote arbeiten. Okay, ich finde gut, dass sie das so offensiv kommunizieren. Ein Tag
ist nice, finde ich gut, also wenn sie das auch so machen. Alle Infos erhältst du hier.
Das Modell flexibel mit Ce... Ke... Kekile. Nein, Cecile heißt das. Aber warum kann es
nicht Kekile heißen? Key... Key Job Details. Berufserfahrene München. In München, da
musst du... Moment, da musst du in München wohnen, da müsstest du schon mal ordentlich bezahlen,
dass sich das überhaupt lohnt. Kuxi, danke schön für den Sub. Ich habe dir die Hälfte nicht mit
gekriegt. Let's Play Gear. Ja, ich trinke, ich trinke was. Meine letzte Abteilung hieß IOM.
Keine Ahnung. Drei Buchstaben abkürzen können alles bedeuten. Was hältst du von Get in IT?
Schick mal einen Link zu irgendeiner Anzeige da. Kann sein, dass wir da schon mal gewesen sind,
aber ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern. So, gleich mal gucken. Ich habe übrigens deine
Session ID gleich mit am Start jetzt, falls es eine Session ID ist. Massive Link, ja. Bin
ich eingeloggt? Nee. Okay, lass doch mal kurz ProSieben fertig gucken. Unternehmens... Das
erwartet dich bei uns. Als Netwerkadministrator gewährleistest du zusammen mit dem Team
vielfältigen Unternehmensnetzwerke mit... Ja, bla bla bla. Du berätst unsere Fachabteilung und bist
in Projektgruppen hinsichtlich der Nutzung von Infrastruktur, Topologien oder Komponenten. Du
arbeitest und bewertest Betriebskonzepte, außerdem planst und designst du Optimierungen. Du bist als
Ansprechpartner bei Störungen des Monitoringsystems. Okay, klingt vollkommen reasonable. Das bringst du
mit. Okay, die übliche Geschichte. Du hinaus verfügst bereits auf mehrjährige praktische
Berufserfahrung in komplexen Netzwerklandschaften. Netzwerksystemlandschaften. Zudem hast du sehr
fundierte Kenntnisse im Bereich Multilayer Switching. Nö, habe ich nicht. Routing habe
ich auch nicht. Routingprotokolle habe ich auch nicht. BGP habe ich auch nicht. OSPF habe ich
ein bisschen. iGrip habe ich auch keinen Effekt. Das ist doch die Cisco-Variante, oder? Äh, auch nicht.
Sowie 802.11 Sternchen. Die wollen einfach alle Netzwerkstandards. Da wird einfach schon mal...
Interessiert keinen. Einfach alle Standards. Okay, 802.11.x. X sind, genau, Security-Geschichten,
Port Security und sowas. Und IPsec. Cisco. Firewall-Loadbalancer. Was ist das? Software-Defined
Networking oder sowas. IaaS-Technologien. Python. Vielleicht sollte noch irgendjemand mal über diese
Stellenanzeige drüber lesen. Ansible oder Terraform sind für dich keine Fremdwörter. Das wäre aber auch
das Einzige, was ich davon hätte. Das ist auch so eine typische, das ist so eine typische Marketing,
Marketing-Spruch, sowas hier. Du siehst, also so eine typische BWL oder Personalabteilung-Spruch
in einer Stellenanzeige. Du siehst eine Problemstellung als Herausforderung und erarbeitest
je nach Komplexität eigenständig oder mit dem Team und den Kunden gemeinsam konstruktive Lösungen.
Niemand hat sich das morgen, nachdem er aufgestanden ist, gedacht, oh geil, ich kann jetzt auf die
Arbeit fahren und endlich dann Problemstellungen als Herausforderungen sehen. Ich meine, ich weiß,
was sie damit meinen, aber das ist ein 0815 Generic-Satz. Eine extra vergütete 24-7-Rufbereitschaft.
Ah, das muss nicht schlecht sein. Es kommt, es kommt. Ohne Mist, Leute, das muss nicht schlecht
sein. Erstens bedeutet es nicht, dass dieser Typ 24-7 da sein muss, anwesend sein, erreichbar sein
muss. Es ist einfach so, dass es genug Leute geben muss, dass 24-7 abgedeckt werden können. Und dann
kommt es sehr stark darauf an, welche Systeme als wichtig definiert werden, für die diese
Rufbereitschaft aktiviert werden darf. Es werden sicherlich nicht alle Systeme sein, weil es wird
dann einfach zu teuer, weil Rufbereitschaftseinsätze werden mit Sicherheit nochmal extra vergütet.
Und wie gut und stabil denn diese als wichtig definierten Systeme sind. Also das kann sich
tatsächlich lohnen. Also ich kann dir sagen, ich kriege über 10k oder um die 10k im Jahr durch
Rufbereitschaft. So über den Daumen gepeilt nochmal oben drauf. Und ich muss nicht oft Rufbereitschaft
machen. Und Rufbereitschaft ist bei uns nicht nur nachts, sondern auch morgens. Und morgens bin
ich eh schon wach, ab wann die losgeht. Wie oft machst du Rufbereitschaft? Also aktuell mache ich
das noch gar nicht. Ich gucke ab und zu morgens schon ein bisschen mit drauf, weil ich bin noch
zu neu. Ich bin erst dreieinhalb Monate da. Ansonsten, also nachts ist glaube ich zwei oder
dreimal im Monat, wo du potenziell nachts angerufen werden konntest. Und Kollege meinte
irgendwie, er wurde glaube ich nachts in den letzten drei Jahren oder so nicht angerufen.
Und dann gibt es bei uns halt noch nicht nur die Sache mit nachts, sondern auch noch, also früh,
das musste halt von 7 bis 11 erreichbar sein. Und dann musste von 7 bis 12 erreichbar sein. Und dann
gibt es noch eine zweite Sache von 12 bis 18 Uhr und dann nachts. Also das juckt mich überhaupt
nicht. Zumal unsere Einsatzzeiten, wie schnell wir vom Rechner sein müssen, auch mega großzügig
sind. Und dafür nehme ich für kaum was machen müssen, nehme ich die 10k gerne mit. Aber man
muss halt sagen, die Firma macht es richtig aus meiner Sicht. Die haben sich das halt mal
durchgerechnet. Die haben gesagt, okay, wir können jetzt ordentlich Kohle ausgeben für die Leute,
dass die verfügbar sind. Aber wenn es mal Probleme gibt in wichtigen Systemen, wo uns
Ausfälle gleich Millionen kosten, dann haben wir das Geld quasi instant wieder drin, weil die Sachen
schneller gefixt sind. Das haben die genau so durchgerechnet. Und im Endeffekt ist es nice für
mich. Böse Zungen behaupten quasi, es wäre ein Infinite Money Glitch. Finde ich aber nicht. Es
haben beide Seiten was von. Und es wurde garantiert gut überlegt und gut durchdacht. Und man hat sich
dafür entschieden, weil es im Ernstfall einfach Millionen kostet. Ist doch nice. Also wie gesagt,
wenn es gut gemacht ist und die Systeme taugen, muss das nicht zwangsläufig was Schlechtes sein.
Das bieten wir dir. Nichts. Ach doch. Ein schwarzes Loch. Wie oft der kreist,
ist der da wechselt. 10 Leute ungefähr. Für die paar Systeme, wo es bei uns,
wo wir für mit zuständig sind. Es gibt ja glaube ich nur drei größere Systeme bei uns,
wo das wirklich so definiert ist, dass du in der Rufbereitschaft angerufen werden kannst. Aber
ne ne ne. Es wechselt permanent, weil bei mir, im Team die Leute sind mega clever. Die machen das
nicht am Stück. Die machen das abwechselnd. Weil du dann immer, wenn du das abwechselnd machst.
Frag mich nicht, wie es genau funktioniert. Aber das ist schon ein bisschen, wie gesagt,
schon ein bisschen Money Glitch. Wenn du die Sachen passend timest, kannst du mehr Bonus
Zulagen abgreifen. Weil es irgendwie einen Unterschied macht, ob du. Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum es so ist. Ich könnte mir jetzt irgendwas ausdenken. Ich weiß es gar nicht, warum es so
ist. Wahrscheinlich, weil es irgendwie Bonus Zulagen gibt, wenn du von ner Rufbereitschaft
zu nem Arbeitstag oder von nem Arbeitstag in die Rufbereitschaft irgendwie. Frag mich nicht. Keine
Ahnung. Aber die timen das so, weil es nochmal extra Money gibt, wenn man das gut timt. One
Shoe Slap. Dankeschön. C++ bleibt uns erspart. POG Subscription. Ja ne, das finde ich aber in
Ordnung, dass da, dass die Python drinstehen haben für Netzwerksachen. Ja, ich hab grad.
Zur Zeit viel Streams. Ja, das stimmt. Ich bin abends auch meistens zu sehr im Arsch,
dass ich irgendwie was wirklich noch so krass Produktives daheim machen könnte. Deswegen,
wenn ich eh schon halb Bett getime ist, dann mach ich immer nochmal Stream an. Wir können abends
ne Runde schwätzen. So, also ProSieben ist durch. Ey, Moment. Das Bieten, wir hatten
ja noch. Breit Trainings, 30 Urlaubstage. Okay, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen N-Wow. Ich dachte,
dass das Flexibel heißt. Heißt das jetzt N-Wow? Oder heißt es Flexibel? Die könnte ich auch nicht
entscheiden. Aber 30 Urlaubstage sind okay. Normalerweise sind das doch nur 26, oder? Ne,
Moment. Bei mir sind es 26, normal sind es 30. So ist das, oder? Ich bin verwirrt. 30 sind,
ne, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr. Ja, gesetzlich ist 26, aber relativ normal ist 30.
Genau. Bei mir sind es ja anteilmäßig weniger. Deswegen komme ich da immer durcheinander. Okay,
man kann bis zu einem Monat aus dem Urlaub quasi arbeiten. Das ist nice. Bei uns arbeitest du
eigenverantwortlich in, in was? Cross-Divisionalen Teams. Ah, die meinen Abteilungsübergreifend
quasi. Aber Abteilungsübergreifend klingt kacke. Cross-Divisional klingt einfach geiler. Teams mit
neuen Zukunftsweisen, Technologien, Erstürzter Bayern. Bla, bla, bla. Ja. Äh, Berlin? Ah,
nee, man kann sagen München. Okay. Ehrlich gesagt, so schlimm klingt das gar nicht. Bisschen
nichtssagend, was die einsetzen, ja. Aber so schlimm klingt das gar nicht. Ich finde das
eigentlich durchaus brauchbar. Boah. Alter, man. Die Seite ist schon ein bisschen, bisschen bad.
Das Modell flexibel mit Cecile. Oh nee, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch. Ist das,
ist das Cecile hier? Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Das ist sicherlich nicht Cecile. Das ist irgendein
Stockfoto. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich DSGVO. Aber solange es aus Spanien und so geht,
ist doch top. Weil Spanien, da kannst du auch nach Gran Canaria oder so fahren. Das ist ja
dann auch EU. Oder? Wenn es Spanien ist. Nee, die Franzosen sind clever. Die Franzosen sind
clever. Das habe ich letztens erst gelesen. Viele Überseegebiete und Inseln von Frankreich zählen
nach irgendeiner Verordnung nicht zur EU. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das auch bei
Inseln gemacht haben, dass Leute nicht versuchen, da wieder mit irgendwelchen Booten hinzuschippern,
zu fliehen und dann zu sagen, ich stelle Asylanträge und sowas. Vermutlich haben das,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ob die das deswegen gemacht haben. Aber viele, viele von diesem
Überseegebiet und Inseln, die Frankreich gehören, habe ich letztens erst gelesen,
gelten nicht als EU. Das Problem ist halt, wenn die das merken, verstößt du halt gegen Auflagen.
Das gibt bestimmt Probleme. So, dann lass uns doch nochmal hier, lass uns doch nochmal die
anderen zwei Sachen schnell angucken. Gucken wir den hier mal noch zackig an. Ice Dark Team.
System Engineer in Kassel, Bochum, Koblenz Home Office. Holla, Teilzeit. Du findest dich hier
wieder. Ich habe noch gar nichts über euch gelesen, Mann. Wie soll ich mich da wiederfinden? Ja,
also. Ausgestattet mit einer ausgeprägten Problemlösungskompetenz. Bist du die Schaltzentrale
moderner Analytik-Infrastrukturlandschaften. Boah, jetzt geht es zur Sache. Immer ausgerichtet
auf die Anforderungen unserer Kunden arbeitest du in abwechslungsreichen Projekten. Okay,
bla bla bla. Agile sind sie. Bla bla bla bla. Okay, seid überzeugt. Bla bla bla bla. Okay,
wo geht es denn jetzt eigentlich los? Hier. Implementierung und Betrieb von Dateninfrastrukturen
on-premise und in der Cloud. Okay, ja, klingt passend für einen System Engineer. Problembehebung
und Dokumentation der Systemlandschaften. Das ist schon der erste Fehler. Die rechnen damit,
dass sie Fehler machen. Das ist das erste Problem. Ihr wisst, wie das ist. Wer keine
Fehler macht, braucht keine Dokumentation. Easy. Aber ja, das ist natürlich auch passend dazu.
Kundenkommunikation bei technischen Fragen. Okay, Sicherstellung der Stabilität. Okay,
dein Profil. Du überzeugst mit guten Kenntnissen die Administration von Linux-Systemen.
Strukturierte Arbeitsweise. Idealerweise hast du schon Erfahrung mit Bash, Python und interessierst
dich für Tools wie Ansible, Puppet oder Terraform. Klingt auch naheliegend für diese Sachen.
Cloud-Anbieter, AWS, Azure, Google sind dir ein Begriff. Ja, passt auch dazu. Du punktest
in Kenntnis über Security, Authentifizierungsverfahren, im Idealfall PAM, LDAP, AD oder
SAML. Ja, okay, klingt auch passend. Du interessierst dich für Container-Anwendungen.
Ja, also das Profil klingt gut passend dafür. Das hier ist halt super generic 0815,
was ich mega Resident Sleeper finde. Was wir bieten. Unternehmenskultur. Okay. Flexible
Homeoffice. Ja, da würde mich natürlich interessieren, was genau. Okay. Jobticket,
Bike Leasing, Bahncard. Ja, oder jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach Deutschland-Ticket.
Anspruch auf ein Diensthandy. Ja, das ist auch okay. Frisches Obst, natürlich Kaffee,
kalte Getränke. Obstkorb muss sein. Zuzahlung zu Internet und Land. Was? Zuzahlung zu Internet?
Wie? Wenn ich Homeoffice mache zu meinem Internetvertrag oder wie Anbieter. Ja,
also das hier ist gut gewählt oder recht passend zu dem Überschritt. Aber das finde ich halt sehr
0815. Gerade das Intro sehr 0815 generic. Aber geht klar, denke ich. Ist jetzt aber nicht so
spannend, dass ich sagen würde, oh, das interessiert mich aber wirklich, was dahintersteckt oder ich
würde mich bewerben oder so. Ups. So, dann machen wir den als letztes hier nochmal. Cloud-Plattform
Kubernetes-Engineer. Das war's für mich jetzt. Aber ich suche ja gar keinen Job. Echt? Okay,
zu meinem Internetvertrag bezahlt keiner was dazu. Ohomo in Polen ist, glaube ich, echt
problematisch. Ist das wie Fahrtgeld? Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht, was die darunter meinen.
Okay, Cloud-Plattform Kubernetes-Engineer. Sternchen. Ah, ach, okay. Die haben keinen
Bock, MWD dahinter zu schreiben, so wie alle anderen. Was es zumindest auch von der Überschrift
her mal ein bisschen klarer lesbarer und abhebt. War gar keine schlechte Idee,
aber sie schreiben da natürlich drunter, dass das alles egal ist und sie die... Hauptsache,
du bist Five-Head. Ja. Finde ich gar keine so üble Idee. In Teilzeit oder Vollzeit? Das finde
ich auch immer gut, wenn sie da beischreiben, dass Teilzeit möglich ist, weil dort, wo ich
mich beworben habe, stand eigentlich Vollzeit dabei. Aber es ging trotzdem mit Teilzeit.
Cackweight. Hast du den Zoom über 100%? Ja, ich habe den, glaube ich, auf 300% oder so. Ne,
150. Ab sofort auf Karlsruhe, Köln, München, Hamburg, Pforzheim, Erlangen, Berlin. Gucken wir
uns das Ganze mal an. Aha, guck mal hier. Du implementierst exzellente IT-Infrastrukturen,
also Five-Head-only. Leute, da musst du mindestens fünf Prime-Subs hier gelassen haben,
dass du dafür schlau genug bist. C++-Stream? Ne, wir haben es nochmal abgewendet. Haben genug
Leute Prime-Subs. Zumindest bis jetzt. Wer weiß, sind ja noch 45 Minuten. Tüftelfelix,
danke schön für den Sub. Okay, gerade nochmal Glück gehabt, Leute. Kein C++ heute. Nice, Felix.
Ach, Taze, du willst nur da bleiben, wenn C++-Stream ist? Okay. Leute, ich sehe schon,
demnächst müssen wir erstmal einen serious C++-Stream einplanen. Please no C++. Enix,
danke für den Sub. Haben wir geschafft. Okay, wir übernehmen Verantwortung für Qualitätsmerkmale
wie Sicherheit, blablabla, richtige Skalierung, Automatisierung, verstehe, blablabla. Bei uns
verläuft kein Projekt wie das andere, je nach Kunde. Ich weiß nicht, die tun immer so, als wäre
das ein Vorteil. Ich lese das immer so, wir wissen nicht so genau, was wir treiben. Aber
ich weiß, dass sie das positiv meinen. Je nach Kunde und Team-Technologie-Stack ist die Lösung
einzigartig. Unser Fokus ist jedoch immer dasselbe mit innovativen Technologien und einem hohen
Anspruch an die Qualität. Unsere Lösungen wollen wir nicht nur unsere Kunden glücklich machen,
sondern auch uns selbst. Nice. Na dann. Ist halt die Frage, ob sie den Cloud-Plattform-Engineer
auch glücklich machen. Okay, übliches, übliches, blablabla-Intro. Was du bei uns bewegen kannst.
Ich hoffe das Geld auf dem Konto. Als Teil eines agilen Teams baust du mit moderner Cloud-Infrastruktur
und Container-Plattformen das Fundament unserer Projekte und gestaltest robuste und wartbare
Architekturen. Ja, klingt vollkommen gut und passend für einen Cloud-Plattform-Engineer.
Machen exzellente Infrastrukturen. Du arbeitest über und unter der Haube von Container-
Orchestrierungstools wie Kubernetes. Im Idealfall liegen deine Expertise auch in der infrastrukturnahen
Entwicklung, zum Beispiel im Kubernetes-Ökosystem. Ja, auch vollkommen logisch für einen Kubernetes-
Engineer. Du hast Erfahrung mit diversen Architektur- und Betriebskonzepten und
nichts sagen. Schon bei der Konzeption und Entwicklung der Anwendung planst du den
späteren Hochverfügbarkeits-Engineering. Okay, ein bisschen nichts sagen, aber ja,
passt irgendwie dazu. Im Team verfolgt ihr das gemeinsame Ziel, die bestmögliche Lösung für
den Bedarf. Blablabla. In unseren Projekten verwenden wir häufig folgende Technologien.
Container-Orchestrierung. Kubernetes. Das ist die AWS Elastic Kubernetes Gedöns. Ich weiß gar
nicht, wie der Kram heißt dort richtig. Elastic Cloud Services. Elastic Dings. Ach,
was auch immer. Azure Kubernetes Service. Google Kubernetes Engine. K3S und KubeEdge. Was war
KubeEdge? Was ist ECS? Elastic Container Service. Aha. Programmiersprachen im Cloud-Kontext. Go
Python Bash. Ja. Also ich finde gut, dass da Go dabei steht. Go ist bei vielen Cloud-Native-Tools
ja angesagt und unten drunter. Infrastruktur-Management, Automatisierung, Terraform
Ansible. Vollkommen passend dazu. Public Cloud Provider soll man sich auskennen mit Amazon,
Google und Microsoft. Auch passend. CI-CD-Tool. GitLab Go CD. Das kenne ich jetzt persönlich
nicht. Free und Open Source CI-CD-Server. GitHub, Azure DevOps. Ja, gut. Auch logisch. Verteilte
Systeme. Ja, passt. Also ich muss sagen, die Anforderungen sind sehr gut passend, was ja auch
nicht selbstverständlich ist. Sehr gut passend zu dem Job-Titel oder zu der Job-Bezeichnung an
sich. Das finde ich schon mal nicht schlecht. Und es ist auch ein bisschen konkret, was die
benutzen. Also das finde ich schon mal nicht verkehrt. Die halbe Seite Selbstlobpreisung
hätte man sich wieder sparen können. Die suchen ja nicht nur eine ganze Abteilung,
sondern ja, wir finden das gar nicht schlecht. Also passt wirklich ganz gut dazu. Ist halt die
Frage, ob der Rest auch stimmt. Dein anfangs gewählter technologischer Schwerpunkt. Wer gut
zu uns passen würde. Ausbildung abgeschlossen. Studium gemacht. Praxiserfahrung. Der Jura.
Glück gehabt. C++ Stream abgewendet. Dankeschön für den Sub. Hogu. Du hast den Anspruch,
neue Technologien einzuarbeiten. Gut, ja. Das ist IT-technisch ja eh Pflicht. Wobei man sagen
muss, ich sag das immer so. Mit der IT-Technik immer Pflicht und ich sag das ja auch in meinen
Videos. Aber auch bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt es genug, gerade etwas ältere Leute, die ich jetzt
schon auch teamübergreifend erlebt habe, die absolut keinen Plan von neuen Sachen haben und
sich vor allem auch nicht dafür interessieren. Das Gegenbeispiel ist, bei mir im Team ist einer,
der geht in einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr in Rente. Der ist schon in Altersteilzeit und
ist eigentlich fast weg. Und der lernt gerade Terraform. Hat noch nie was mitgemacht. Hat
früher Solariskisten administriert. Und jetzt kommt er an den Start. Zeig mal ein bisschen
Terraform. Das geht auch anders. Ich bin aber auch ein über 30 Boomer. Aber ich mach halt auch
Technik-Streams. Und mich interessiert der Kram ja auch. Es gibt viele, die schalten dann schon
ab und denken, ich mach mein Ding und fertig. Du hast ein gutes Gespür für die richtige Balance
zwischen Pragmatismus und Perfektionismus. Das, finde ich, haben sie schön geschrieben. Du kannst
komplexe technische Zusammenhänge auch nicht technisch vermitteln. Sehr gut. Da kann ich
gleich was zu sagen. Flexible Arbeitszeiten, Vollzeit und Teilzeit, Homeoffice, Workation.
Ah, das heißt, man kann im Urlaub mal kurz sich einloggen. Für ein paar Wochen. Und Auszeit.
Oh, Auszeit. Ich mache ab dem ersten Tag direkt Auszeit. Auszeit, beste. Geld her und Auszeit,
please. Erhöhter Zuschuss. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass sie das so meinen. Ja, die meinen damit eher
so nach dem Motto, es kommen Entwickler zu dir, denen sollst du Infrastruktursachen erklären.
Oder es kommt irgendein Projektleiter zu dir und fragt dich, okay, wie sieht das mit der Technologie
XY aus? Du kannst das denen erklären. Ich finde, das gehört schon ein bisschen dazu. Dass man auch
in der Lage ist, Sachen, also spätestens wenn man eine Senior-Position hat, aber auch normal,
das gehört irgendwie schon dazu, dass man die Sachen ein bisschen verpacken kann. Hoher
Freiheitsgrad durch flache Hierarchien und kurze Entscheidungswege. Okay, das schreiben irgendwie
alle, oder? Ob es dann wirklich so ist, sieht man erst später. Innovative Technologien. Okay,
Leute, habt ihr irgendeine Ahnung, was Brown Bag Sessions sind? Ich lerne nie aus an komischen
Begriffen aus Stellenanzeigen. Was ist eine Brown Bag Session? Brown Bag Meeting genannt. Ein
informelles Treffen während der Mittagszeit. Ach, man futtert was und redet dabei über die Arbeit.
Okay, man macht... Ah ja, okay. Brown Bag Session, alter. Es ist der Wahnsinn, für was es alles
irgendwelche dämlichen Worte gibt. Das ist garantiert Arbeitszeit, wenn nicht, wer gebetet.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Also arbeitsrechtlich würde ich sagen, funktioniert das folgendermaßen. Das
ist Arbeitszeit und du darfst danach nach einer halben Stunde Pause machen, beziehungsweise du
kriegst auf jeden Fall eine halbe Stunde Pause abgezogen auf deiner Zeiterfassung. Ihr meint
wirklich, das ist keine Arbeitszeit? Also ich rede auch während der Mittagspause ganz gern mit
irgendwelchen Leuten über irgendwelche Technikthemen und so, aber nicht gezwungenermaßen. Dann hätte
ich da keinen Bock drauf. Wenn schon, mache ich das freiwillig. Ja, stimmt. Und wenn du den ganzen
Tag isst, kannst du den ganzen Tag Brown Bag Sessions machen. Sehr gute Idee. Einfach den
ganzen Tag fressen und wenn dann irgendeiner reinkommt und fragt, was machst du da eigentlich,
sagst du Brown Bag Session. Das ist eigentlich die beste Idee überhaupt. Das ist aber eine gute
GBA-Taktik. Das ist eine gute GBA-Taktik, weil freies Futter wollen alle immer haben. Freie Wahl
des Hardware- und des Betriebssystems. Oh, Leute, ich bin einen Schritt näher an. Nein, ich suche
keinen Job gerade, aber das wäre für mich ein großer Pluspunkt. Ich wäre nicht dazu gezwungen,
Windows zu benutzen. Google sagt, das ist keine Arbeitszeit. Aber wollen wir Google wissen, wie
das dort gehandhabt wird? Okay, alles. Gar nicht schübel. Geht voll klar. Man hätte sich halt diese
Lobpreisung am Anfang wieder sparen können, aber ansonsten geht auch voll klar. Gar nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß nicht, wer es gepostet hat, aber ich denke, da kann man sich bewerben. Du darfst dir auf der
Arbeit kein Linux inszenieren. Ja, doch, aber nicht auf meinem offiziell zur Verfügung gestellten
Arbeitsnotebook. Da muss Windows mit dem Standard-Blödsinn drauf sein. Ach so, doch, stimmt. Das
haben wir ja auch noch. Wo habe ich denn das? Habe ich das gerade zugemacht? Doch, doch, stimmt, weil
ihr es seid. Ich habe ja gesagt, wir gucken uns das an, wenn es gepostet wird. Ach, das ist eine Jobs-Seite.
Okay, Berufsfeld. Ganz schnell. Ein Berufsfeld. Was haben wir da? Web-Entwicklung, System-Engineering,
Admin. Was haben wir ansonsten? Ach komm, machen wir das einfach mal hier. In welcher Stadt Frankfurt?
Ja, okay. Und was ist jetzt an dieser Seite gut im Vergleich zu allen anderen 0815-Bewerbungsgeschichten?
Homeoffice möglich? Bitcoin? Bitcoin sucht Fachinformatiker? Die heißen einfach zufälliger so.
REWE. DevOps-Engineer für die Streaming-Plattform. REWE. Ja, bei PwC bin ich auch direkt im
Onkashake-Mode, wenn ich die sehe. Ich hatte in der Berufsschule einen in der Klasse, der hat
bei PwC gearbeitet. Das sind so zur Erklärung, das sind so Wirtschaftsprüfer. Wie heißen die?
PricewaterhouseCoopers oder so? Coopers. Und Coopers, ja. Zumindest, ich hatte in der
Berufsschule einen in der Klasse, der war richtig schlau. Ohne Mist. Das war der Beste in der ganzen
Berufsschulklasse. Und auch von Leuten, die ich so getroffen habe, war das einer der, der sich
wirklich gut ausgekannt hat und auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, das professionell alles gemacht hat.
So wirklich ein guter Mann. Und was war? Er hat einen scheiß Prüfungsausschuss erwischt und er
ist da mit einer 3 rausgegangen aus der Prüfung. Das war der Beste in der Schule. Ohne Mist. Der
war wirklich gut, der Kerl. Nicht nur in der Schule. Und da hat PwC gesagt, ja, wir nehmen
nur Leute ab einer 2 in der Abschlussprüfung. Und ich war in Pech gehabt, ja. Achso, ich wollte,
ich wollte auch was zu Container sagen. Ja, mich interessieren die ganzen Container-Technologien
auch sehr. Aber wie soll, wie soll ich an einen Job rankommen, wenn ich gar keine
professionelle Erfahrung mit dem Zeug habe? Sorry für den Uniproß. Also, das ist ganz einfach. Du
beschäftigst dich einfach damit und dann bewirbst du dich, weil du hast ja wahrscheinlich schon
einen Technik-Background. Und wenn du einen Technik-Background hast, mal angenommen, du hast
Physik gelernt, hast jetzt, keine Ahnung, als Windows-Admin gearbeitet für 4 Jahre und du
beschäftigst dich jetzt privat damit, dann bewerbst dich einfach auf so eine Stelle. Sei es intern oder
extern. Warum nicht? Du kannst doch sagen, hier, 5 Jahre Erfahrung in Technologie in dem und dem
Bereich. Und du kannst ja dann auch eine Skill-Auflistung mitschicken. Ich habe Erfahrung
mit Kubernetes, Cloud-Plattformen, das und das, Helm, alles mögliche. Dann schreibst du das einfach
rein und bewirbst dich. Wo es ein bisschen schwieriger ist, wenn du gar keinen technischen
Background hast und quasi vorher irgendwie Schreiner warst und sagst, okay, ich hatte,
ich habe noch nie professionell in der IT gearbeitet und habe mich privat ein bisschen
mit Kubernetes beschäftigt. Ich hätte jetzt gerne, ich hätte jetzt gerne einen Job. Möglich ist das
auch heute, sowas. Aber es ist deutlich schwieriger. Von denen haben wir auch ein paar Kandidaten auf
der Arbeit. Wobei ich sagen muss, die meisten davon sind gar nicht so ganz schlimm planlos
konsultant. Die gehen eigentlich. Ja, dann ist doch top. Dann weißt du doch, hast du doch Ahnung von
Technik-Sachen. Und wenn dich Container-Kram interessiert, easy, schnappt dir daheim einen Mini-Cube,
bau Kubernetes auf. Danach machst du weiter, machst dir einen Probe-Account bei irgendeinem,
die haben, die haben die Kohle doch. Dann machst du dir irgendeinen Cloud-Probe-Account,
Trial-Account bei Azure, bei Google oder weiß nicht, ob AWS sowas auch hat. Beschäftige
sich ein bisschen mit Managed Kubernetes. Es gibt noch ganz viele Möglichkeiten, was zu machen,
ohne dass du in dem Bereich professionell arbeiten musst. Und du wirst sehen, die Containerisierung
Kubernetes-Thematik explodiert. Also ich meine damit von der Komplexität her. Du fängst an,
denkst, ich blick eigentlich ganz gut durch und dann siehst du, wie kompliziert das ist. Also
ich sag mal so, du musst dich ungefähr zwei, drei Monate wirklich, sagen wir mal täglich oder,
ja oder zumindest, ja doch. Also sagen wir mal, du musst dich zwei, drei Monate, also wenn du
wirklich gut reinkommen willst, musst du dich zwei, drei Monate täglich ein paar Stunden damit
beschäftigen. Wenn du wirklich von ganz Grund auf anfängst. Aber dann hast du auch ganz gut planen.
Das heißt nicht, dass du wirklich alles schon so hundertprozentig durchstiegen hast, aber du kannst
mitreden. Das ist ja immer prinzipiell das Wichtigste. Du kannst mitreden, du kannst auch
sowas aufbauen und du weißt Bescheid. Du kennst nicht jedes Produkt, was irgendwie was mit
Kubernetes zu tun hat oder jedes Submenü von Azure auswendig oder sonst was in der Richtung. Aber wenn
du dich zwei, zweieinhalb, drei Monate wirklich intensiv mit Kubernetes beschäftigt hast und da
auch alle möglichen Sachen ausprobiert hast, ein paar Stunden am Tag, dann blickst du da durch.
So habe ich das damals auch gemacht. Also ich habe zwei, drei Monate einfach, weil es mich
auch persönlich sehr interessiert hat, zwei, drei Monate Hardcore-Kubernetes-Camping gemacht. Wir
haben sogar hier im Stream ein bisschen gebaut damit. Und jetzt zahlt es sich im Endeffekt aus.
Aber es ist immer schön, wenn man einen Antrieb hat von sich aus, weil einem das Thema interessiert.
Also und dir scheint es ja zu interessieren, Immutable Bytes, sonst hättest du nicht gefragt.
Fast schon. Und wenn du dich halt nicht jeden Tag damit beschäftigen willst, dann machst du das halt
nur ein paar Tage in die Woche und brauchst dann halt vielleicht drei, vier Monate, bis du richtig
guten Durchblick hast. Aber das geht schon. Das ist kein Hexenwerk, da durchzuplicken. Es ist aber
ein sehr, sehr komplexes Gebiet. Aber wichtig ist, dass man die ganzen Sachen schon mal irgendwo
gesehen und gehört hat, sodass man das einschätzen kann, um was es geht. Das ist ja in vielen
Technikfeldern und IT-Richtungen so, dass du das alles gar nicht so sehr im Detail alles immer aus
dem FF wissen musst. Aber du musst wissen, um was es geht, sodass du relativ schnell durchblickst.
Du kannst zum Beispiel auch nicht alle möglichen Loadbalancer, Proxys, Webserver und sonst was
kennen. Aber du musst wissen, okay, was machen die Dinger, was müssen die Dinger so können.
Loadbalancer, Sticky Sessions, irgendwelche Proxy-Geschichten, was auch immer. Und dann
kannst du schon mal gezielt nachgucken, wenn es bei neuen Produkten, okay, wie gehen denn diese
Sachen dort. Und so ist das im Kubernetes- und Containerisierungsumfeld auch. Du wirst erst mal
ganz einfach anfangen mit, wie mache ich einen Docker-Container, wie mache ich ein Docker-Compose-File,
wie uploade ich mein Image in eine Registry. Dann wirst du ein bisschen mit Docker rumbasteln,
dann wirst du dir irgendwann mal einen lokalen Minikube Kubernetes installieren und wirst dort
rumbasteln. Dann wirst du feststellen, ach Mist, wie ist das so mit Storage im Kubernetes, gerade
lokal schwierig, weil da musst du dich selbst drum kümmern. Cloud-Anbieter machen das für dich. Wie
ist das mit Loadbalancer-IP-Professionierung? Cloud-Anbieter machen das für dich lokal mit
einem Minikube und so musst du dich da selbst drum kümmern, mit Metal-LB oder sowas. Und dann
lernst du so links und rechts die einen oder anderen Sachen kennen und guckst dir das ein
bisschen an. Du musst dir halt ein paar gescheite Versuchsaufbauten überlegen, was du so machen
willst. Sag keine Ahnung, ich möchte eine Web-Anwendung hosten da drauf, die automatisch
skaliert auf der Basis von irgendwelchen Prometheus-Metriken und ich will meinen Cluster
vielleicht backupen und ja, ich will automatische Zertifikate mit Let's Encrypt. Ich will ein
Secret-Management anbinden, dass ich keine Passwörter im Klartext installieren muss,
als Secrets anlegen muss. Ja, solche Sachen und dann hast du einen schönen Anwendungsfall und
dann baust du das mal. Und dann baust du so, dass es möglichst, sagen wir mal, aus deiner Sicht ein
gutes Production-Ready-Setup wäre und dann musst du dich schon mit vielen, vielen Themen beschäftigen.
Ich meine, live wird das Ding nirgendwo gehen, aber... Und dann weißt du Bescheid und dann kannst
du dich bewerben und dann werden die dich auch nehmen, weil die suchen händeringend Leute,
die sich mit Containerisierung und dem Cloud-Umfeld gut auskennen. Ja, du bist ja auch im ganz anderen
Bereich aktiv. Ich wette mit dir, wenn du mir was von Embedded Register oder sowas erzählst,
ist bei mir auch direkt instant vorbei. Wusstest du, dass bei Microsoft extra Geld für Backups
zahlen muss? Ich dachte bis heute... Ja, das wusste ich. Es ist übrigens bei vielen Cloud-Anbietern
so, dass du... Es ist... Was heißt bei vielen? Es ist eigentlich bei allen Cloud-Anbietern so,
dass du extra Geld für Backups bezahlen musst, weil das braucht Speicherplatz und das musst du
bezahlen. Das ist eigentlich normal. Mir fällt kein Cloud-Anbieter ein, wo Backups kostenlos
wären. Vielleicht, vielleicht haben irgendwelche super mini free Contingente... Ne, wie heißt das
Wort? Contingente. Aber meistens musst du das bezahlen. Kennt jemand einen guten Kurs,
um eine Programmiersprache zu lernen, gerne auch praxisorientiert? Ich glaube,
ich habe in letzter Zeit keine Einstiegsteigerkurse für Sprachen mehr geguckt. Such dir doch erstmal
eine Sprache raus, die du machen willst. Also ich persönlich würde ja immer JavaScript empfehlen,
wenn man gar nicht weiß, mit was man anfangen will, weil die einfachste... Weil der einfachste
Einstieg einfach mit JavaScript möglich ist. Du brauchst einen Texteditor und einen Webbrowser,
das war's. Ja, also bei Exchange wusste ich es nicht, aber es gibt die Möglichkeit auch bei
anderen Sachen. Ja, Udemy hat teilweise ganz gute Kurse, das stimmt. Ja, Pauschalkurse sind blöd,
du musst dir schon eine Sprache raussuchen. Ich überlege eine Umschulung zu wechseln... Was?
Moment, ich überlege meine Umschulung zu wechseln auf Fachinformatik, Anwendungsentwicklung,
bekomme einfach kein Praktikum. Äh, wie? Es ist vollkommen egal, ob du Physi oder AE gelernt hast,
unterm Strich. Du kannst bei beiden die Jobs machen, die du haben willst. Ganz frisch nach
der Ausbildung ist es vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger, wenn du dann explizit an Fachinformatik
oder Anwendungsentwicklung bist, aber ganz ehrlich, jemand, der Physi gelernt hat,
einen von beiden und sich fürs Programmieren interessiert und das schon... Das geht beides.
Ach, du machst eine Umschulung als Kaufmann für E-Commerce. Ja, da hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf,
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall lieber Physi machen. Das andere klingt ja eher so BWL-Shit-mäßig.
Glaub mir, das habe ich auch früher gemacht. So ein Kram willst du nicht machen. Was heißt,
das habe ich auch früher gemacht. Das stimmt nicht. Ich habe das nie früher gemacht. Ich habe eine
Ausbildung im BWL-Bereich angefangen und festgestellt, dass das der größte Shit ist und dann wieder
aufgehört damit. Und ich habe die Ausbildung auch nur angefangen, weil mich meine Mutter so sehr
genervt hat, dass ich doch endlich mal was machen soll. Und außerdem haben wir ja auch... Genau,
genau. Und außerdem ist der Fachinformatiker doch auch ein halber Kaufmann, lauter IHK. Also insofern
ist doch top. Kannst du vielleicht sogar ein bisschen Berufsschule skippen. Okay,
wir wollten uns ja dieses Ding hier angucken. Streaming-Plattform von Rewe. Okay, was ist denn
jetzt der Vorteil von dieser Jobseite? Schreiben die da Gehälter drauf? Ansonsten sieht das für
mich aus wie ein 0815-Stellenportal. Was ist denn jetzt der Vorteil davon? Warum habt ihr mir das
geschickt, Chatge? Die Unternehmen bewerben sich bei mir. Das sieht aber hier anders aus, ehrlich
gesagt. Da muss ich immer noch auf jetzt bewerben klicken. Aber es geht beides. Das heißt, ich kann
hier filtern. Oben rechts in die Ecke. Lass dich jetzt... Ach so, du musst da... Ja, das ist ja im
Prinzip das Gleiche, wie wenn du ein ordentliches LinkedIn-Profil hast und nicht die ganzen
Headhunter voll spammen. Vielleicht nicht ganz so penetrant. Immutable, bye. Danke für den Sub. Okay,
was suchen die denn? In Frankfurt? Aha, Cloud Computing, DevOps, GoHelm, Kafka, Kanban, Plus8,
Kubernetes, Linux, Monitoring, RESTful, Scrum, Software. Das wäre doch genau das Richtige für
mich. Nur, dass ich keinen Job suche, aber okay. Gut, Kafka habe ich keine Ahnung von, aber der Rest
ist Peter Aguilé direkt am Start. Dein Home of IT, Rewe Digital. Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla. Das ist ja, dass die immer mit so einer Lobeshymne auf sich selbst anfangen
müssen. Können die nicht gleich mal zum Punkt kommen? Du bist mittendrin auf Grundlage eines
Kafka Ökosystems. Es haben wirklich Leute geschafft, das ordnungsgemäß einzurichten und zu
betreiben. Das ist nämlich ohne. Kafka Cluster, Strimzi, Restbridge, Strimzi. Das klingt irgendwie
ein bisschen wie ein Schweizer Wort, oder? Ich bin nicht, ich kann Schweizer Akzent schlecht
nachmachen, aber irgendwie klingt das ein bisschen schweizerisch. Strimzi. Restbridge, Kafka Connect,
Mirror Maker, Schema Registry. Mirror Maker 2, IBM. Also ich kenne die Strimzi, Restbridge nicht.
Strimzi.io. Ach, das ist einfach nur ein HTTP Interface davor. Du übernimmst Verantwortung,
technische fachliche Konfiguration, verautomatisierst die Komponenten, passt wunderbar dazu. Du fühlst
dich in deinem Element. Kubernetes, Helm und GitLab Pipelines. Ja, würde ich mich tatsächlich in
meinem Element fühlen. Du hast alles im Blick. Cloud, On-Prem, Edge werden von uns support und
laufen auf jedem Hyperscaler. Alter, das ist auch so ein geiles Wort, Alter. Der Satz ergibt doch
eigentlich gar keinen Sinn, oder? Cloud, On-Prem und Edge werden von uns support und laufen auf
jedem Hyperscaler. Aber hä? Also ergibt der Satz irgendwie Sinn? Ich dachte eigentlich,
dass ein Hyperscaler quasi ein Synonym für Cloud-Anbieter ist. Im Endeffekt ist Azure ein
Hyperscaler. Warum auch immer man das so nennt, fragt mich nicht, wer auf diese bescheuerte Idee
gekommen ist. Aber ich meine, On-Prem kann ja logischerweise schon mal nicht in der Cloud
laufen. Sonst wäre es nicht On-Prem. Außerdem bin ich ja der Meinung, diese Abkürzung On-Prem
irgendwie triggert die mich. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich kann es euch nicht erklären, aber das ist so
ne super neumodisches, cooles Wort für, wir haben halt ein eigenes Rechenzentrum, wo noch Kisten
rumstehen, die wir betreiben. Man könnte einfach lokal schreiben, oder eigener Standort, oder
offline. Ja offline trifft es nicht so ganz. Ihr wisst was ich meine. Ich finde On-Prem irgendwie
so ein blödes Wort. Aber davon abgesehen ergibt dieser Satz absolut keinen Sinn. Cloud, On-Prem
und Edge werden von uns support und laufen auf jedem Hyperscaler. Der Satz macht null Sinn. Oder
ich bin zu 3Head das zu kapieren. Career Lunch. Kenn ich nicht. Ja da spawnt einfach Hardware im
Rechenzentrum. Das ist nice. Ja. Der Satz ergibt, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie macht es mich, verstehe
ich nicht. Na gut, was auch immer. Obwohl ich das eigentlich verstehen sollte, weil ziemlich viel
von dem gehört, also außer Kafka jetzt, mache ich tagtäglich und verdiene mein Geld mit. Aber
ich habe keine Ahnung, was die mir mit diesem Satz sagen wollen. Du bist Problemlöser. Du
hast Lust auf Squalierbarkeit, Hochverfügbarkeit, Portierbarkeit und einfaches Deployment. Und
einfache Deployment. Machst du einfache Deployment. Du bist ganz vorne mit dabei. Du
enabler. Du bist halt so ein richtiger Enabler. Du enablest und unterstützt Produktteams in der
Transformation, die Streamingplattform richtig anzubinden. Moment, die Streamingplattform ist
ihre Kafka-Message-Infrastruktur, oder? Annick, und baust du mit uns eine? Okay, ja, das meinen
die. Du bist ein Teamplayer. Du arbeitest in einem cross-funktionalen, selbstorganisierten Team.
Kann man Scrum? Ja, okay. Okay, es geht noch weiter. Features, die dich ausmachen. Begeisterung
für eine Data-Streaming-Plattform. Verständnis von asynchroner Kommunikation. Kafka JMS. Ist das
was ActiveMQ macht oder RapidMQ? Chat, ich habe immer noch die Frage an euch, ob sich irgendjemand
mit RapidMQ ein kubernetes Umfeld auskennt. Sonst muss ich mir das selbst angucken. Eine
abgeschlossene Ausbildung. Ja gut, okay. Routine im Umgang mit Softwarearchitektur und Cloud-Umgebung.
Routine? Alter, was, was Sätze, was soll man sich denn darunter vorstellen? Ja, ich habe Routine
mit Softwarearchitektur. Okay, also ich entwerfe routiniert Software mit guter Architektur. Das
wollen die mir damit sagen, quasi. Was ist asynchrone Kommunikation? Ja, zum Beispiel über
eine Message-Queue. Überleg dir, du hast einen Webshop, ja, und irgendjemand schickt jetzt einen
Auftrag ab im Shop. Dann landet das in der Message-Queue, dann wird der Auftrag bearbeitet,
dann wird die Zahlung prozesst, dann werden die Waren eingepackt, dann wird das verschickt,
was auch immer. Also halt alles, was nicht synchron ist. Zum Beispiel über eine Message-Queue. Das
ist damit gemeint. Ja, oder noch einfacher, noch einfacher. Bestes Beispiel, wo man es, glaube ich,
am besten versteht. Jemand registriert sich für eine Newsletter. Der Newsletter selbst wird
allerdings bloß einmal in der Woche verschickt. So, der Typ registriert sich über ein Webformular,
dann landet das irgendwo drin und dann wird halt einmal in der Woche geguckt, wer sich registriert.
Das zum Beispiel wäre sowas wie asynchrone Kommunikation. Sehr oldschool-mäßig, aber sowas
in der Richtung ist damit gemeint. Aber bei Webshops ist es relativ klar, auch bei
Auftragsbearbeitung und sowas. Das Schöne an Message-Queues ist ja sowas wie, du musst,
sag mal, dort, wo die Leute shoppen, das hängt dann nicht, weil, sagen wir mal,
das Paymentsystem langsam ist oder das Inventarsystem oder sowas. Und das nimmt dann
einfach sich aus der Message-Queue raus. Der nächste Microservice, der ready ist und dafür
zuständig, nimmt sich da aus der Message-Queue was raus oder bekommt eine Notification, dass was
Neues vorliegt, bearbeitet das und legt dann vielleicht wieder einen neuen Job oder eine neue
Message in die Message-Queue. Ja, das ist damit gemeint. Wir haben RapidMQ im Clusterlaufen. Wie
macht ihr das? Macht ihr das mit dem RapidMQ Operator oder habt ihr irgendwelche eigenen
Sachen gebastelt? Eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung, ja gut. Routine. Ja, ihr habt das mit dem Operator.
Taugt das? Ich will mir das die Tage mal kurz angucken, weil es vielleicht bei uns auf der
Arbeit akut wird, aber ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, wie der beste Weg ist, das zu benutzen.
Linux-Konfigurationsmanagement, Kubernetes, Terraform, Infrastructure. Das passt wunderbar
zu dem Job hier. Du hast ein Tech-Herz und bist begeistert von Technologie. Finde ich gut,
dass sie das reinschreiben. Gerade im Cloud-Umfeld und gerade auch im Kubernetes-Umfeld, finde ich,
gehört das ein bisschen dazu. Das ist so, da spawnen täglich fünf neue Sachen. Nee,
musste nicht. Ich kann mir das selbst angucken. Verfahren mit verteilten Systemen, Kafka, Java,
Python, Go. Find ich gar nicht so schlecht, die Sache hier von Rewe. Ja, fand ich gar nicht so
übel jetzt. Warum ist es Painschamp? Wann geht es mit Zig? Ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie hat es mich
nicht so richtig überzeugt. Ich wüsste nicht, wann ich das verwenden würde, zu welchem Anwendungsfall.
Hatte mich intern als Cloud-Architekt beworben, bin 28, wurde aber abgelehnt und es wurde ein
Dienstleister da bereits für das Unternehmen Arbeit genommen. 50 Jahre plus und die wollen es halt
manchmal nicht besser. Und wenn der Dienstleister dann keinen Bock mehr hat, ist das ganze Know-How
weg. Also gerade sowas sollte man intern besetzen. Ich hätte es ja irgendwie verstanden, wenn die
gesagt hätten, so nach dem Motto, ja, uns fehlen bei dir noch die und die Punkte und sowas. Ehrlich
gesagt, ich finde nicht. In der heutigen Zeit eher nein. Klar. Ehrlich gesagt, im Durchschnitt. Also
es gibt zwei. Es gibt also im Durchschnitt ist das Gehalt, nachdem man studiert hat, höher. Das muss
jetzt aber nicht individuell auf dich zutreffen, aber es ist halt der Durchschnitt. Das nächste ist,
wo es Sinn macht, wenn es dich persönlich eben interessiert, dass du auch theoretische Hintergründe
lernst zu bestimmten Themen, dann kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein. Aber wie gesagt, entweder weil es
dich persönlich interessiert, aber rein aus Gehaltsfragen würde ich ehrlich gesagt das eher
verneinen. Ja, es ist im Durchschnitt so, aber das heißt nicht, dass wenn du jetzt Ahnung hast,
du weniger verdienst, wie jemand, der studiert hat. Ich kenne genug Gegenbeispiele. Leute,
die im First Level vergammeln und studiert haben versus Leute, die Physik gemacht haben und jetzt,
keine Ahnung, Cloud Architekt oder sowas in der Richtung sind. Also rein fürs Gehalt musst du das
auf jeden Fall nicht machen. Ich finde es dann auch manchmal ein bisschen blöd. Also ich sage
nichts gegen Berufserfahrung und es macht aus mehreren Gründen Sinn, dass sowas ältere Leute
werden. Pro und Contra. Das erste ist, dass die Leute den Laden, das Unternehmen, wenn die da
eine Weile sind, kennen und wissen, wie das tickt. Das ist in so einer Architektenposition gar nicht
verkehrt. Die wissen, wo man hin muss, wem man mit wem reden muss, wie man am besten da Sachen
eintütet und sowas. Das ist gut. Vielleicht haben die auch wirklich langjährige Erfahrung in dem
Bereich, wofür sie Architekt sein sollen und können das deswegen besser mit der nötigen
Erfahrung. Gibt bestimmt noch ein paar weitere Punkte. Ein Nachteil ist, gerade wenn es um so
Sachen wie Cloud Architektur geht, dass es das einfach noch gar nicht lang genug gibt und dass
gerade Leute, die 50 plus sind, sich oftmals mit technischen Neuerungen schwer tun. Ich meine,
wenn der jetzt 50 plus ist und zehn Jahre Cloud Erfahrung hat, warum nicht? Aber bei
solchen neuen schnelllebigen Sachen macht es aus meiner Sicht keinen Sinn, jemanden hinzusetzen,
der vielleicht super krasser Architekt für Oracle Datenbanken ist und dem zu sagen,
du machst jetzt Cloud Architektur für uns. Das ist einfach was grundlegend Unterschiedliches.
Was meinst du dazu, dass in einer Firma persönliche Leistungen nicht geschätzt
werden sollen, sondern nur die einfach für den Arsch, Kackfirma? Die sind entweder dämlich,
bestimmt irgendeine Behörde oder so. Persönlicher Einsatz und Leistung ist eigentlich das Wichtigste,
was du bei den Leuten brauchst. Ob die jetzt irgendwelche Zertifikate haben oder nicht,
da sind wir drauf geschissen. Ich meine, es mag vielleicht, wenn du Leute suchst und die
einstellst, dann mag das vielleicht schon ein Kriterium sein für viele. Gerade mal angenommen,
gehen wir mal von wirklich speziellen Sachen aus. Sagen wir mal, die suchen jetzt irgendeinen Cisco
Profi. Wenn du da das ein oder andere Cisco Zertifikat hast, was jetzt nicht gerade ein
CCNA ist, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Und die suchen irgendwie jemand für ganz spezielle,
frag mich nicht, IBM Storage Systeme. Okay, und du hast da ein Zertifikat drin. Macht das sicherlich
Sinn. Aber wenn du erst mal da bist, ganz ehrlich, who cares, was jucken irgendwelche
Zertifikate? Die wissen doch, dass die Leute was taugen, wenn sie da sind. Und dann willst du doch
Leute, die persönlich Einsatz bringen und Einsatz zeigen. Ob die jetzt irgendwelche
Zertifikate oder sich dazu irgendwelchen Kursen anmelden und Zertifikate machen,
ist doch vollkommen, ist komplett lost, ja. Und prinzipiell sollte man eigentlich Leute,
die sich persönlich engagieren, immer fördern oder zumindest sie nicht das Leben schwer machen,
weil das nicht zuletzt oftmals auch die sind, die, wie sagt man so, die Leistungsträger sind
irgendwo. Die halt, wenn es brennt, die Sachen dann auch fixen, weil sie sich halt persönlich
einsetzen. Und nicht so nach dem Motto, ah, ich sehe hier, gleich crasht, glaube ich,
das und das System. Aber ich habe noch kein Incident-Ticket. Ich gehe jetzt erst mal was
futtern. Ich hoffe, dass, wenn der Incident dann auftritt, dass ich gerade beim Essen bin. Ja,
so Leute, willst du so Leute fördern, nur weil sie ein Zertifikat gemacht haben? Und Leute,
die sagen, oh Mist, das System kackt hier ab. Lass mal schnell den Anwendungsverantwortlichen
anrufen und das zusammen fixen. Und denen machst du dann das Leben schwer. Ja, das ist einfach nur
lost. Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine Behörde oder so. Also 400 Stellen zu besetzen, wenn ihr
nicht gerade irgendwie schlagende Argumente habt, also im Prinzip Geld, nicht nur Geld,
ja, Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten und andere Vorteile zählen auch aber im Prinzip Geld. Wenn ihr das
nicht habt, dann wird es schwierig, 400 Leute zu finden. Ja, Leute, schön, dass ihr da wart. Es
ist jetzt Bett-Getime. Ich bin übelst müde. Und der Grund, warum ich letzter Zeit so oft streame,
ist ganz einfach. Ich bin nach der Arbeit, auch trotz Homeoffice, ziemlich kaputt. Gerade,
wenn ich da meine eineinhalb, zwei Stunden auch ein bisschen hier Pepo-Sport gemacht habe. Da bin
ich ziemlich kaputt abends. Da komme ich einfach an, wir schwätzen noch eine Runde und dann ist gut.
E-Max. Ja, wie letztens wolltest du noch nachdenken, dass ich Neowim mache. Und jetzt soll ich E-Max
machen? Auf E-Max habe ich aber keinen Bock mehr. E-Max habe ich eine Weile verwendet. E-Max will
ich nicht mehr anfassen. War ja auch die Schwätz-Streams. Na dann, danke für die ganzen
Prime-Subscriptions heute. Ich muss mal kurz schauen, dass ich noch irgendjemanden übersehen
habe. Umfragen vorgeschlagen. Sollte man eine Position als IT-Berater in einer Behörde annehmen?
Ja, die Umfrage können wir tatsächlich noch machen. Ja, nein. Keine additional words. Okay. Oh fuck,
man konnte die Frage nicht komplett reinpasten. Also die Frage war, sollte man eine Position als
IT-Berater in einer Behörde annehmen? Ja oder nein? Also ich bin der Meinung, ganz ehrlich,
du meinst jetzt irgendwie eingekauft als Externer, falls die sowas machen. Warum nicht? Kannst ja
jederzeit wieder weg. Wann kommt die Amazon-Bestellung? Es ist heute alles angekommen,
außer Milf-Ra. Und auf die Steckdosen warte ich noch. Ja, ich gehe davon aus, dass es eh nur
machen wird, wenn die Konditionen gut sind. Was hast du bestellt, Technik-Camp? Milf-Ra.
Steckdosen. Ja, kein Ding. Wir machen demnächst wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Kubanetes-Zeug
im Stream wieder. Finde ich gut. Ne, so schreibt man das. Das sind Smart-Home-Steckdosen. Da haben
wir bei Amazon Prime bestellt letztens für 9 Euro einen Vierer-Pack. Und da bin ich gespannt,
ob die sich flashen lassen. Okay, der Chat ist so gespaltener Meinung. Zwei Drittel sagen yep
und ein Drittel sagen no pass. 69 easy vote. Nice. Da rollen wir mal rein. So, Chat. Schön,
dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Bedgetime angesagt. Bis morgen. Macht's gut. CU.